voilà Bruno Darou on est dans la
démonstration dans la déclaration on est
dans le symbole oui on est dans le
symbole mais les symboles parfois ça
compte en politique y compris en
politique étrangère donc c'est une
première je crois que c'est la première
fois que les ministres du bloc de
l'Union européenne se réunissent en
dehors de leurs frontières au niveau des
ministres des Affaires étrangères donc
le symbole il est clair il n'y aura sans
doute rien de
décisionnel qui sera effectif
aujourd'hui à l'issue de de cette
réunion mais des comme ceux indiqués par
Emmanuel chass qui vont être discutés
peut-être aussi un peu plus concrètement
d'ailleurs la manière dont l'Europe va
aider l'Ukraine à passer l'hiver et
l'Allemagne propose un plan de
protection hivernale pour aider les
Ukrainiens dans dans les semaines et les
mois qui viennent et dont on sait qu'ils
sont difficiles donc un symbole
vis-à-vis des Ukrainiens un message
envoyé à la Russie non le soutien de
l'Union européenne ne va pas faiblir
malgré ce que déclare le kremelin ce
matin le kremelin qui est clairement
donc dans cette stratégie de l'assitude
comme il dit la ministre française des
Affaires étrangères Catherine Colona de
ce point de vue a employé le même terme
en disant pas du tout il n'y a pas de
lassitude de la part des Européens et
des occidentaux le soutien se poursuivra
il sera pérenne et queles que soi les
circonstances les Européens resteront au
côté de l'Ukraine voilà pas de
l'assitude Caroline des Camaret mais
cette image des 27 elle intervient après
un de mauvais nouvell disons-le pour le
président ukrainien oui c'est-à-dire
j'ai même envie de dire puisque j'ai
reçu le chef de la diplomatie Joseph
Borel la semaine dernière j'ai même
envie de vous dire c'était inextrémist
et inespéré de réunir C ces27 à Kiev
peut-être qu'il n'arriverait pas à le
faire dans quelques semaines et ça c'est
vraiment la question est-ce que c'est
pas la dernière fois qu'on réussit un un
coup pareil tout simplement parce que
vous l'avez dit weekend d'extrême
mauvaise nouvelle pas seulement du côté
de Washington effectivement où l'aide à
l'Ukraine n'était pas n'était pas au
programme du du nouveau budget mais plus
précisément du côté par exemple d'un
pays comme la Slovaquie la Slovaquie qui
vient de porter au pouvoir et bien
certain Robert fitzo hein qui est un
populiste qui a dit qu'il ne donnerait
plus ni d'armes ni d'argent à l'Ukraine
évidemment ça n'est pas une très bonne
nouvelle pour Kiev il est donc il va
faire une coalition aujourd'hui il est
en train de former son gouvernement mais
il a donc ses ses affinités avec
Vladimir Poutine qui qu'il admire
beaucoup avec vict Orban dont il dit le
plus grand bien et avec qui il a hâte de
travailler et puis il a effectivement
par exemple un dossier important du côté
de la liberté de la presse puisqueon
soupçonne son ancien gouvernement et
certains de ses membres d'avoir quelque
chose à voir avec l'assassinat d'un
journaliste donc d'investigation sur la
corruption du pouvoir de Robert fitzo et
de et de son gouvernement donc voilà
pour son pédigré la question qui se pose
aujourd'hui c'est est-ce que l'Europe
est pas en train de prendre le chemin
d'un question sur la Russie et en
particulier est ce que la flamme qui
était véritablement presque éteinte du
groupe de visegrade les quatre pays hein
qui chaque fois étaient antimigrant anti
pro russe et et en tout cas faisait
faisait la guerre à l'Europe fédéraliste
et à l'Europe finalement de nation de
nation communautarisé et bien ces quatre
pays vont pas prendre du poil de la bête
avant on a bien vu que Victor Orban en
Hongrie était seul à être plutôt dans
une rhétorique prorusse maintenant il va
peut-être être rejoint par le slovaque
et puis il y a le 15 octobre voilà des
élections en Pologne où les
conservateurs ont fait campagne aussi
sur des thèses quand même assez assez
hostile et c'était une première par
rapport à à ce qui ce qui s'est passé
auparavant à l'Ukraine en particulier
sur la question du GR du grain et de et
du blé ukrainien qui devait transiter
sur le territoire de la Pologne et euh
et donc et puis il reste la République
tchèque presque est-ce qu'on va pas
reconstituer ce club qui qui est une
minorité de blocage pour pour l'Ukraine
tout ça est assez préoccupant en vérité
oui Bruno finalement est-ce que Moscou
là ne voit pas juste il y a peut-être
pas une lcitude mais il y a des tensions
qui apparaissent clairement dans qui
apparaîtront peut-être dans les semaines
voir les mois à venir oui bah clairement
Moscou est aussi dans une guerre de de
communication donc a bien vu ce qui
s'est passé ces derniers jours aux
États-Unis où pour l'instant l'aide
supplément réclamé par Joe Biden pour
l'Ukraine n'a pas été validé par le
Congrès ensuite effectivement comme le
disait Caroline il y a tout ce qui s'est
passé ce weekend notamment en Slovaquie
même si Moscou dit que c'est absurde de
penser que avec Monsieur fitzo c'est un
proorusse qui a été élu voilà c'est
simplement quelqu'un qui pense à la
souveraineté de son pays aux intérêts de
de ses concitoyens mais clairement la
stratégie russe de toute façon s'inscrit
dans un ton long comme la Russie à la
différence des démocraties moins
confronté on va dire à des échéances
électorales qui peuvent et des échéances
électorales qui peuvent changer aussi la
composition et la nature du pouvoir
c'est beaucoup moins le cas en Russie
Vladimir Poutine se dit qu'il a le temps
pour lui et que le temps et son
principal allié et il sait très bien
qu'au fur et à mesure que les mois vont
passer et bien il y a potentiellement
une forme d'essoufflement de l'assitude
de débat qui émergent dans des sociétés
démocratiques comme aux États-Unis où il
y a de vrais questionnements sur le bien
fondé de cette aide qui pèse sur les
concitoyens par exemple américains en
l'occurrence et à chaque fois que la
Russie peut enfoncer un coin dans cette
unité et cette stratégie de soutien
indéfectable indéfectible pardon à
l'Ukraine et bien évidemment avec un
changement de président potentiel en
2024 aux États-Unis ça pourrait tout
changer aussi bien sûr ah mais ça c'est
c'est c'est un des grands espoirs de
Moscou c'est que et une des grandes
CINES de l'Union européenne n'oublions
pas quand même que l'Union européne
soupçonne fortement Moscou d'avoir
organisé la désinformation sur sur son
sol en particulier des informations très
très vives en Slovaquie où les candidats
progressistes le président de la
Slovaquie progressiste le vice-président
du Parlement européen ont été ciblés par
cette désinformation qui est aidée par
Moscou qui est aidé par des réseaux de
la droite la plus radicale aussi hein
c'est c'est quand même une alliance une
convergence des volontés de
désinformation il y a évidemment les
élections européennes en juin 2024 qui
vont être également ciblés il y aura de
il y a de la information qui s'organise
en Pologne pour le 15 octobre aussi
beaucoup sur les questions de migration
sur les questions de minorités sexuelles
et cetera tout ça est sur la table est
important et va jouer dans la campagne
dans les dernières dans la dernière
ligne droite questionnement sur la
désinformation à à viser des élections
européennes de 2024 où là aussi on se
demande s'il n'y aura pas une grande
offensive des des europhobes en quelque
sorte la droite la plus extrêmes
peut-être même en alliance avec la
droite plus traditionnelle au Parlement
européen donc tout cela et bien c'est
c'est c'est l'ambiance dans laquelle
nous sommes aujourd'hui et et et
l'information sur les réseaux sociaux y
est pour beaucoup aussi des informations
on y revient peut-être Bruno qui avait
permis encourager en tout cas le la
victoire de Donald Trump en 2016 des
informations russes ça avait été avéré
oui ça avait été ça avait été avéré que
clairement les les services russe on va
dire avait joué délibérément la carte de
Donald Trump avait contribué à mettre en
difficulté le camp euh démocrate par
différents moyens on va pas on va pas
revenir sur tous ces détails et
clairement pour la prochaine campagne
Moscou vote à nouveau évidemment Donald
Trump et espère bien que c'est lui qui
va accéder à la Maison Blanche faut bien
quand même rappeler que s'il n'y avait
pas eu Joe Biden qui était en place
depuis février 2022 bien la situation
serait quand même assez radicalement
différente même si le soutien de l'Union
européenne a été quand même très
important y compris finan entirement
d'ailleurs 85 milliards d'euros depuis
février 2022 c'est ce que dit Joseph
Borel que l'on écoutera à 15h merci à
tous les deux